I don't know if any other personality course
in North America talks about Binswanger and Boss anymore maybe not
But I think their ideas are extremely interesting
And so I'm going to talk about them
They were influenced very much by Martin Heidegger
Who was one of the 20th century's greatest philosophers
I would say probably - This school of
This part of the phenomenological school
was more influenced directly by a philosopher than any other school.
And just to reiterate because you might keep wondering why
I discuss so many philosophers in this course
It's because
Clinical Psychology in particular is not strictly a scientific enterprise
It's because it's oriented towards values as far as I can tell
And I don't see that there is any way of getting around that
and that because what you are trying to do as a clinical psychologist
and perhaps what you're trying to do with your own life  is to figure out how to live properly
Now you can construe that as the absence of illness
Which is - That's about as close as you get to a scientific model of living well
So you don't have any illnesses
But even the idea of illness is an idea that's not precisely scientific
It's an amalgam of scientific concepts and ethical concepts
so
There is no escaping it and if you're in the domain of ethics or values
Then you're in what is more or less a philosophical domain
But also if you're a scientist - if you're a scientist who is interested in personality
It's also something you have to grapple with conceptually
Because people live within an ethic and the ethic structures their perceptions
And so even to study human beings as objects
You still have to take into account they ensconce themselves within a value system
and you have to understand what that means
So for me it's easier and more straightforward just to get right to the root of matter to begin with
and these people also had insanely interesting ideas
They're really useful to know
And so this, I would say maybe these
The philosophy that underpins this might be the most complex of all the philosophies
That we're going to discuss
And that's really saying something because there is no shortage of complexities say in Jung
And it's very difficult to portray what these people were up to
I started by telling you, when we discussed Rogers a little bit
That the phenomenologists were interested in the fact that people live within a self-defined perceptual world
That might be one way of thinking about it
Part of the way to start to conceptualize what that means is to consider for a moment
just consider for a moment how many things there are in this room that you might look at
and the answer to that is there's an infinite number of them
Depending on how you're going to scale your perceptions
You could spend, if you were a painter, you could spend a month painting that tile
Painting a representation of that tile because it's infinitely complex
To get the colors right, to get the patterns right, there's no end to it really
Because to make a representation that was accurate
It would have to be as detailed as the thing itself and it's crazily detailed
But you don't concentrate on that sort of thing
So you think, you're surrounded by an infinite number of potential things to apprehend
But that isn't the world you live in
The world you live in is a very very constrained subset of those things
And part of the question is then: what's the nature of that constrained subset
That's what you inhabit that's what makes up your experience
And also how is it related to the infinitely complex objects that are around you
And that's really what these people were trying to figure out.
So you're in this perceptual frame, that's one way of thinking about it.
That's the Dasein, by the way
That's the existential frame or the phenomenological frame
Because you can't think about it merely as perception
Because it contains also, all of the things you experience subjectively
The emotions and the Qualia that
You know Qualia is an element of being
that say philosophers or scientists of consciouness have a particularly difficult time with.
And it's like - it's the quality of pain which doesn't seem reducible to a set of  objective facts
Or the quality of color, or the quality of beauty, or the quality of love, or the quality of sorrow
Those things seem irreducible to some degree in and of themselves
Like what is pain made of? It doesn't even seem like a reasonable question.
I mean you can say, how do you decompose the neurological circuits that are involved in the experience of pain? Fine.
But to ask what pain consists of or is composed of or what beauty is composed of, or love.
Seems to be -  There is something wrong with the formulation of that question
Because those things sort of manifest them self as raw facts of existence
And so they're constituent elements of this - of your field of experience
Your phenomenological frame or this Dasein
Which is the way that Heidegger conceptualized it.
That's being there with you at the center of your what? Your realm of experience
Now here's some characteristics of the Dasein
The thing that makes up you
The past and the present are implicit in it
What does that mean?
Well, say you have a particular emotional response to something, maybe it's a negative emotional response.
And you see this very frequently with arguments with people
You're having an argument with someone you love. Like a family member, that's a good example
So lets say it's the same damn fight you've had with your mother 50 times
Okay that's interesting because what it means is that
All of those 50 times you've fought with your mother are implicit in this fight
So althought it's taking place right here and now, the past has shaped it
And if you wanted to investigate the fight completely
You'd have to get to the bottom of that entire train of interactions you've had with your mother
So it's implicit in your current experience that's one way of thinking about it
But the future is implicit in it too because
What you're doing right now, it's as if the future is folded up in what you're experiencing right now and it unfolds as you interact with it
And so the reason it's conditional to some degree on you and your past is because
it's your past and you that are determining the actions that you undertake right now that determine how the future is going to unfold around you
Now not completely obviously because you don't have complete control over how things unfold
But you seem to have some ability to determine how things unfold
So one of the ways I've sort of conceptualized the phenomenological viewpoint
This is one way of thinking about it I believe is that
Instead of thinking - It does mean you have to reconceptualize your idea of objects
Like an object seems like a unidimensional thing in some sense. It's an object.
But most of the things people interact with aren't like that at all
So like here's an example
Let's say you have
Let's say you get
You're writing the MCAT, you want to go to medical school
You've written the MCAT, you get the envelope in the mail, it tells you what your score is
You hold the envelope, what are you holding?
Well if you think about it from an objective perspective, it's an envelope
Who cares? It's just a little piece of paper right?
It's a rectangle of paper
But that isn't what you're holding at all
That's not what that thing is, that's how you see it. But it's not what it is at all and you know that. Your body knows that
Because you're shaking. Well, what are you scared of? The envelope?
Well the fact that you see it as an envelope is only an indication of just how narrow your perceptions actually are.
Because it's a portal.
Right? it's a portal through which you are going to walk into one of two worlds
One in which you're in medical school and the other in which you're not
And it also actually contains the past
Which is really strange because you think, well you already know what the past is. No you don't.
Whatever that score is in there determines what your past was and you know that too.
You go watch a movie and a bunch of things happen in the movie and then something twisted happens at the end  and all the sudden (trilling)
Everything that you thought about the movie was wrong
and a whole new past for the movie pops into being
Well, are you a pre-med student? A valid pre-med student? Well the score will determine whether or not you were.
Very strange, very strange
Because you think of the past as fixed
You know? And you think of the things you're interacting with as the things that you see and they're not
And you're body is smarter than that, way smarter than that. Because it responds to, you could say
And this is sort of a Rogerian perspective, your body is more likely to respond to what the thing actually is, than how it is that you see it.
Okay so, the past is implicit in the current being
and the future is implicit in the current being
And so the past and the future sort of folded up inside it
And you can unfold them and take a look at them
Now, here's the next thing
So, from a classic scientific perspective,
There's the world of independently existing objects and there's the world of subjects
And the subject is really in a secondary relationship to the object
Because the objective world is what's real
But one of the things that the phenomenologists were concerned about that
Is that, well you run into this problem again of exactly how it is that you define the object
Because, just as the envelope with the scores in it can't be reduced to the paper,
So the object that you're interacting with only reveals what it is as a consequence of the way that you interact with it
So for example if you take a complex object like another person
It's like well, what is it that you are. Well a huge part of that is going to depend on exactly how I interact with you
Because you could be a raging beast if I interacted with you one way
and you could be a perfectly, you know, cooperative entity that was very pleasant if I interacted with you another way
And so partly what's happening - you can think of what you're interacting with as something that's really multi-faceted. Truly multi-faceted
And you say, well you're trying to determine what it is.
But the problem is that what it is manifests itself only in accordance with how you behave towards it
And it's actually the case with even objects that you reduce right down to their constituent elements
So you might say like lets talk about subatomic particles. Hypothetically, the most objective thing there is
Well it turns out that whether they're a wave or a particle depends on the way you set up the experiment
Now I don't want to make quantum analogies but what I'm saying is that the object is a very very complicated thing
And so even defining what it is means you have to adopt a frame of reference with regards to it
And you undertake only some procedures and not others
So, when you're defining an object even scientifically you actually don't define the object.
What you say is here is a multi-dimensional entity if you approach it in this manner, that's the procedure, right? The methods.
If you approach it in that manner, it will manifest that set of traits
But the problem is, is that there's all sorts of other traits that it could manifest just as well
If you treated it a different way
And so the object itself is not something that - it's not something easily reducible to a single set of properties
I was talking to one of my students yesterday, he had a pretty smart thing to say about images.
We were talking about deep images you know the sorts that you might see in a really high quality museum
So maybe they're I don't know 15th century or 16th century renaissance  masterpieces
They're inexhaustible to some degree
Which is why they're in museums and people go look at them you know decade after decade
And it's partly because
Every time you look at them you're different
You go in one week, you look at it, you see something. You go in the next week, you look at it and you see something else.
Well it's partly because
You're bringing something entirely different to the situation
and the image is complicated enough to allow it to reflect something new to you depening on the stance you take in relationship to it
And lots of things are like that
lots of things are like that
A book you read when you were sixteen is going to be an entirely different book when you read it when you're 35
Say well the book's the same. It's like, it depends on how you define the book
Because it isn't even obvious where the book is exactly
Well it's on my shelf in the library
It's like no, that's a chunk of paper that's on your shelf in the library
Where exactly the book is, that's a much more difficult question to consider
So it depends on how you define the book
So without a subject, nothing at all would exist to confront objects and to imagine them as such
True this implies that every object
Everything objective in being merely objectified by the subject is the most subjective thing possible
Well you also know this again when you're in an argument with someone
"it's you"
"no, it's you"
"no it's you"
It's like, you don't know
Are you being biased? Are you looking at the situation incorrectly?
The person you're arguing with trying to convince you that it's your problem
You think "no you made me angry"
It's like hmm an interesting statement you know? as if you could do that
But it does seem that way, you were being provocative
"Well you're just too sensitive"
"hmm how are we going to settle that?"
Well it's a continual argument and that again has to do with the crazy entangled dynamic between subjective perception and objective perception
I've showed you this before and I actually think this is a pretty good
Schematic representation of what's meant by Dasein
And this is a complicated little diagram
Although the diagram itself is quite simple
It's predicated on the following assumptions
You need to narrow down your world
and what you're doing is narrowing it down from lets say an infinite set of possibilities
To a finite set of manageable possibilities
and you do that a bunch of ways
Partly - merely - you can't your senses aren't acute enough to detect everything.
So pure stupidity in some sense stops you from being absolutely overwhelmed
You don't have eyes in the back of your head for example so you don't have to worry about all those things you're not looking at behind you
But then it's far more than that
You just can't handle that full complexity so there's a continual narrowing process
And then you exist inside that narrowed reality
Like if I look at you like that
There's not a hell of a lot of difference between that looking at you like that
Like I can't really see these people. I can tell they're people, that's all
I can see your face
I've got just about all of it right there
That's a very narrow and you know you're moving your eyes around
and inhabiting this constant narrow space
Well what's that space - what does that space you inhabit consist of
Well that's Dasein that space that you inhabit and so we can say
It's something like this
You have implicit in that perception a sense of where you are and what you are doing right now
it's in the perception
and then in the perception as well is what you're aiming at
Because you're not just sitting here passively or you'd be asleep or you'd be unconscious
You're sitting here doing nothing
You know, physically
But you have an aim in mind and the aim is what you're pointing your eyes at
The aim is what's structuring your perceptions
The aim is what's revealing that part of the world that is being revealed to you, to you
That's the revelation of the world
It also structures your emotions. It also primes your behaviors
So it's not a drive, it's not a goal
it's not a motivation, it's more than that. It's all of that at once.
That's sort of what your personality is
You see the phenomenologists don't really think about personality
They think about the manifestation of your reality
It's not exactly your personality
It's that you're the center of a reality and you constitute that reality
But all of your elements of experience constitute that reality and so it's simplest element is something like
Where you are and where you're going and the embodied actions you undertake to relate those two things
Which would include your eye movements because of course perception is an active phenomena
You are shaking your eyes back and forth unbelievable rapidly
Otherwise, if you can make your eyes stand still, which you can do with great concentration
Everything will black out
Because you have to move your eyes back and forth so the light hits different cells cause the cells get exhausted
And then they stop reporting. So you're just whipping your eyes back and forth in a micro-way constantly
And as well as moving them around voluntarily and involuntarily
So even perception is a lot more like feeling things out with your fingers
Even when you're using your ears or your eyes
It's very active, there's no passive perception
it's a motor act to perceive
and so your motor act is determined by your hierarchy of values that's one way of looking at it
So another way of thinking about it is that's how the past and future are implicit in it
Your very active perception is determined by your entire value structure
So
It's implicit inside of it, it's folded up inside of it
You can tell that too because if something violates it
Again, maybe an argument with someone
It's good to think about people as the thing you interact with the most as the canonical object
Cause they're so damn complicated and they get in the way all the time and when someone gets in the way of what you're doing
You know, it isn't obvious what they're interfering with
It might be the little micro-routine that you're undertaking right now
You know, maybe you go home and you make a nice dinner and the person you're making it for is all rude about it
Okay so what exactly are they getting in the way of?
Well
They're certainly getting in the way of your expectations of having a nice emotional time for the next hour
But you have no idea how indicative that is of some serious flaw
In you, or them, or the relationship, or the situation, or the way you've conducted your whole life
Or the way they've conducted their whole life
and all of that's packed in there
It's sort of like the unconscious of the psychoanalysts
but it's more - it's not the same conceptualization. It's another way of looking at the same phenomena
So
Alright so the two people we're going to talk about most are Medard Boss
And he was influenced by Martin Heidegger, who was a great philosopher
Taken to task often because he turned out to be tangled up with the Nazis more than he should've been
And Husserl, that's Edmund Husserl, who was actually if I remember correctly was Martin Heidegger's teacher
That's Ludwig Binswanger - and they were
Both of these two people were influenced both by Freud and Jung
Okay so here is one of Binswanger's claims
I love this claim it's such a cool idea
And I think there is neurological support for it. Neuropsychological support
What we perceive are "first and foremost" not impressions of taste, tone, smell or touch
Not even in things or objects, but meanings
Well that's an interesting idea
Because
You know it's been said that every person in an unconscious exponent of some great philosopher's presuppositions
Well, mostly the way you think about the way you perceive is that there are objects in the world
You see the objects
You think about the objects, you evaluate the objects
You decide how to act on the objects, and then you act
Right? it's from
Object, sense, perception, emotion, cognition, action
That's wrong. That isn't how it works
It's partly not the way it works because
You're actually - the way that you interact with the world exists at multiple levels
So for example
You have reflexes so if I
If I poke you hard, you'll react like that. You'll jerk back
And that, you do that without thinking
That's part of a neurological circuit that's very deeply embedded and that's virtually automatic
It's reflexive. It doesn't require conscious perception at all
It's too slow for starters
And so you have - there's multiple levels of you interacting with the world.
And at one level, you're seeing objects, you're thinking about them, you're planning what to do
But you're doing all sorts of other things that are way faster than that and other things that are way slower at the same time.
Now what Binswanger claims
Is that what you see in the world are meanings
So it's the meaning detection first and the object recognition second
Now that's a hell of a claim, that is
But there's definitely levels of your nervous system
That operate in that manner
So for example
Here's a good example, people have blind sight
There visual cortex is damaged they can't see objects
So they think they're blind
But if you show them an angry face, they'll manifest a change in the skin conductants, They'll orient
And it means that the eyes are still mapping the face onto the amygdala
And the amygdala is mapping the pattern onto the body, no object perception
Pattern
No object perception
And so the meaning is what's being perceived first and foremost
And you have to perceive meanings first because you actually want to stay alive
That's the trick
So the world is full of these things that have meanings to you that are relevant to your survival
And what you're perceiving first is the relevance of the pattern to your survival
And the idea that you can conceptualize that as a set of objects
Well first of all, that's a pretty new idea
Technically speaking, right? Because
Technically speaking we didn't really start to conceive the world as subject in an objective world until we really formalized science
Now science was implicit long before it became explicit
But it didn't become explicit until about 500 years ago
So you react to meanings
So here's an example
Babies
if you
If you have two surfaces and you put a piece of glass between them
You know, they're elevated
And you put an 8 month year old baby on the one surface so they can crawl
It won't crawl across the space
And you might say it sees a hole and won't crawl across it
But that isn't what it sees. It sees a place to fall off
Direct, that's direct perception
So when I see this for example
My eyes see that as a pattern
That pattern's on my retina it's propagated through my optic nerve
It's propagated into my brain, it's propagated onto my motor cortex
And the propagation is
This
That
Right? So I can pick it up
And as soon as - when I look at that this is implicit
That's implicit in the perception
You think well why do you see that at the size and resolution you see it at?
That's why
So the fact that you see it that way has this implicit in it
It isn't that you see the object and match your hand to it
It's that matching your hand to it is part of the perception of the object
It's what gives the object meaning
And so you see actually you perceive the meaning of the object
It's part of the perception
And you can't not see the meaning of the object
Well if you're a scientist you can sort of separate out the object from its meaning
That's actually what science does
It tears the object away from its meaning
And then of course there is nothing meaningful left
So science ends up value free. But that's because the meaning has been torn out of it
Now there's technical reasons for doing that
But Binswanger's point is don't kid yourself you see the meaning first. Here's an example
You watch the trade towers fall
What did you see?
Well you could say you saw the towers fall
It's like why are you in shock for two days afterwards then?
Well because what are the towers exactly?
As long as they're standing and operating, they're towers.
As soon as they fall, God only knows what they are
Maybe they're the beginning of the next war
You know? Who knows what they are?
And so everyone was in shock for three days
Because what they saw was the indeterminate meaning of that event
And it opened all sorts of gateways
It's like well, the towers fell, there's gateways open everywhere.
We don't know what's going on. We don't know what's going to happen next. We don't know where we are
And that's direct perception mapped onto your body. Bang, you're in shock
You see the meaning first
And well you constrain it down to well why are you so upset?
Well the towers fell
It's like that's the best you can do for a verbal utterance
It's what your perceptual systems reported to you
But God only knows what happened
We still don't really know what it meant that they fell
Now most things have put themselves back together but
And then you think well what does it mean?
What does it mean that what you see first is the meaning?
and that's a really tricky question because you might say well
That's when you get back to the problem of what constitutes real
So I could say well you've evolved to see the meaning
Well then we might ask
Well if you've evoled to see the meaning and that's kept you alive
Is there anything more real than the meaning?
Because somebody who is a materialist would say "well no, the object is more real"
It's like no, it depends on how you define real
It might be that the most real thing about the visual cliff is that that's a falling off place
And that its secondary description as a you know an object
A hole or something like that
That's something you paint over the top of the primary reality
And so,
Well here's a practical application of it or at least one of the things I think is practical
You know, you can have experiences that differ in their, lets call it, high quality meaning
You know so you get engaged and engrossed in something and you're happy about that
It's not that you're happy
It's that you're engaged and engrossed in it, you would do it again
Even though it might take effort
You can tell that where you are is meaningful
Well I think what happens in that situation is that
You're in a Piagetian place
Where many of the games that you're playing are stacked sort of isomorphically on top of one another
And the experience of meaning is the fact that you're playing a small game properly
Nested inside a larger game, you're playing it properly
Nested inside a larger game, you're playing it properly too, etc all the way out
Past is balanced, future is balanced everything is stacked up
And there's a report coming from your being telling you that, that's why you're engaged
You might say well maybe that's real. Maybe it's more real than anything else
That's a strange thing because if you think that meaning is separate and secondary from the real objective world
Then the reality is the object
But it isn't obvious that the reality is the object
It's certainly not how we act
It's not how we perceive
And so
Did we evolve to perceive reality? It depends on what you mean by perceive
Perceive might mean did we evolve mechanisms that allowed us to survive in the face of that reality. Yes.
Is that whats real? What enables you to survive in the face of reality?
It's a definition
It's a perfectly reasonable definition unless you can come up with a better one
Meanings are primary
Now that brings up a strange issue
So what determines the meaning of what it is you're perceiving
Well this is where Binswanger and Boss disagree
Binswanger says
It's the a-priori ontological structure. The world design, or matrix of meaning
Okay so what does that mean?
Well, you have a particular history. Biological and cultural and individual
And you're viewing the world through the lense of that set of particularities
So it's almost if you are behind a curtain and the curtain has certain hoels in it
And you can see through the wholes in the curtain
but the curtain is your construction so the curtain with the holes determines what you see
Well, Boss would say no it's the opposite in a very strange thing
The meaning of the world manifests itself to you more or less of its own accord
And
It's a tougher one to explain
Disclosure of meaning: Boss the revelation of the object
The emergence of the phenomena: the numinous
The very word phenomena is derived from phainesthai
To shine forth, to appear,  to unveil itself, to come out of concealment or darkness
Okay here's an example you see someone beautiful
Is it your perception
is it your perception or does the beauty exist?
That's the difference between Binswanger and Boss
Cause Binswanger would say well the reason that thing appears to you as beautiful is because of the way you're filtering it
And Boss would say no
The beauty inheres in the object itself and manifests itself. It shines forth
And so I really like this concept this concept of phenomena
That's why they're phenomenologists
phainesthai means to shine forth
From the phenomenological perspective you pursue those things that shine forth
Now you remember this is kind of a parallel idea
I suppose it's a parallel of Jungian ideas
You remember in Harry Potter that when they're playing Quidditch he's always chasing the snitch?
And you remember how, if I've got this correctly,
Quidditch is basically two games at the same time right? There's the standard game and there's the game that the seekers play
Yes? I've got that right?
What happens if the seeker gets the snitch?
Games over right? They win
Very interesting. She has a brilliant imagination that woman, Rowling
So the idea is that in every game there's two games going on at the same time. There's the ordinary game
And there's the game that the seekers play and the seekers chase the thing that shines at them
And that's what that little thing is the snitch. It's a round circle with wings.
It's a very very old old old symbol
It's a symbol of what
It's a symbol of reality before it's fractionated into its parts
I don't know how to say it any more clearly than that
It's a symbol of
Imagine that there are things that move forward to make you curious
And you were trying to figure out what was common among all the things that made you curious
That thing that Harry Potter's chasing, that's a symbol of that
It's golden like the sun, it flits around and attracts your attention and it's always moving
And if you're seeking, you chase it.
So that's the phenomenological idea, that's the disclosure of meaning
You say well when you're curious about something, why are you curious about that?
Is it calling to you? Or is it something that you're interpreting?
Well I would say it's both
I think that's the way to resolve this puzzle
It's that
There isn't a perceiving entity without a structure
And your structure has been evolving itself for three and a half billion years
There's no perceiving entity without a structure
But by the same token the thing that's being perceived
Also shines forth with its own potential manifestation
And you need to think of it both ways at the same time
But the curiosity issue is a really fascinating one
Because curiosity pulls you forward
It's not random
That's the thing that's so cool
You can't really control it, but it's not random
If your curiosity is random, you're schizophrenic
And I mean that technically
Because one of the things that happens to schziphrenics is that the mechanisms that establish relevance become pathologized
And they see meaning everywhere, randomly
And that's partly why they generate delusions
Because the incoherent manifestation of meaning calls out for a representation
They develop a paranoid delusion if they're intelligent enough to put everything together
So you're curious and something pulls you forward
Well you can interact with the curiosity  and you can follow it but you can't really direct it
The question is where is it taking you?
So that little ball, that was a manifestation
Of what the Greeks referred to - Greeks? Is that right? - Mercurius
It's a Roman and Greek God Mercurius
The spirit Mercurius is the messenger of the Gods. The winged messenger of the Gods
It flits around
You say well the curiosity pulls you forward
To where?
Well to wherever it wants to take you
Well that's a Jungian idea as well
Is that your curiosity is like the manifestation of your self to the ego
Right? It's the thing that you could be in the future calling you forward
Something like that
Very strange idea
Very interesting. See when you start to understand
That you're not in control of what makes you interested in things
The whole world shifts around on you
Because the question is if you're not in control of that, what the hell is directing it?
What's going on?
It's not you
It's not under your control
It's not random. It's alive. It's dynamic
It has an orientation towards something
That's the Jungian self.
Or that's the manifestation of meaning
Yes very strange
I told you this already
See there's an old representation, a very old represenation of the snitch right there
Now this is an old symbol, eh?
You've got this dragon of chaos here
It's kind of like an octopus as well
That twist in its tail refers to infinity. Dragons almost always have an infinite tail like that
And it's got the claws of a bird, maybe a bird of prey
The body of an animal and the head of a snake
And then down here
You see its got the sun up there so it's sort of aiming upwards towards the sun this thing
And then down here is this thing called the round chaos. It's an old alchemical system
And if you look the dragon is fertilizing this
And that has potential in it like an egg
It's full of potential
And so it's matter and spirit at the same time
It's sort of like it's a representation of that which you're exploring
Because you could say well the thing that you're exploring
It's sort of a constructivist idea
You explore something new
What do you generate from the exploration?
You. Because as you explore it you learn things. That changes you.
So you generate psyche out of the exploration. That's spirit.
And you also generate the world out of it
But the thing to begin with is psyche and world at the same time
And that's what this thing represents
And that's what Harry Potter is chasing
That's what makes him a seeker
Very strange ideas
Now I'm going to tell you a dream
There was a dream I had while working on these ideas
And I'm going to tell you the dream for two reasons
One is because it bears directly on these ideas
Two because well we just covered psychoanalytic thought and I want to show you how a dream can work
Cause it's not easy to find a dream that you can interpret in a way that's public that makes sense
Cause they're usually so tightly defined contextually
You can define them in the therapeutic context because you know so much about the person
It's very hard to pull that out and make it meaningful outside of that context
But this dream works. Ok so,
I was dreaming
I was dreaming that there was a small object. It was a circle, a sphere about this big.
And it was floating on top of the Atlantic Ocean
And I had kind of a birds eye view of it and I was following it along
Like maybe you know like a drone would follow behind an object
And it was floating
And it was really zipping along man, it was really really fast
And then the scene shifted
To a bunch of scientists they were sitting inside a room full of television monitors
And they were watching this thing move across the Ocean
And so it was here and it had four hurricanes beside it one here, one here, one here, and one here
So it was in the center of four hurricanes
So whatever it was was like some bloody potent thing zipping across the ocean
Then the scientists got a hold of it I guess and the scene shifted
And I was in a museum like an old Victorian museum
And this thing, this ball was now inside a
Imagine a wood stand
With a glass case on top of it
It was inside the glass case and it was floating and it was sort of pulsing a little bit
And so inside the room there was Stephen Hawking
And the American President
I don't remember who it was he was sort of faceless
But Stephen I thought, Stephen Hawking? What the hell
Disembodied intellect
That's Stephen Hawking so that's what that meant
And the President well he's just the symbol of order
And so this thing whatever it was that was surrounded by these winds
Had been placed into a category system right?
It was in a museum, it was boxed in. It had been conceptualized and categorized
Partly by disembodied intellect, that was Stephen Hawking,  and partly by social order
And so there's a Binswanger Boss thing going on there
The thing pulses and is alive so its got its own power
But it's also encapsulated in a category system
So I'm a third person observer in there I'm not in the room I'm just seeing this
So that was fine
So the next thing that happened
Oh yes, one of them described the features of the room
Its walls were seven feet thick
They didn't want this thing going anywhere
And it was made out of titanium dioxide
I thought, what the hell is that?
Well it's a paint
It's a paint substance but it's also what the hull of the Starship Enterprise is made out of
So my dream was saying well what's the hardest substance there is? Well it's titanium dioxide
It's not getting out of that box
The walls were designed to permanently constrain the object
Okay now the next thing that happened was this object was
You could tell it was kind of alive
And it kept shifting around and at one point it turned into a chrysalis you know a cocoon
And I thought what the hell does that mean?
And then, so it turned into a cocoon
And I don't know if you've seen a chrysalis when it's just about to hatch
But it twitches around eh? It's alive that thing
So they're very strange things
And then at the end it turned itself into a pipe
Like a Meerschaum pipe
And I thought
Then it reformed itself into a sphere
And just shot right out of the room
Like the walls weren't even there
It decided it was gone bang! It was gone
And I woke up and I thought what the hell
What the hell does that mean?
It took me forever to figure this out
So then about two years after experiencing this dream,
I was reading Dante's Inferno
In the ninth Canto, a messenger from God appears
So Dante goes down into hell right?
It was Dante's attempt to describe
It's brilliant
So imagine that you go to a bad place psychologically right?
So your life has collapsed that's terrible
But then you're trying to figure out what you did wrong and how you're to blame for it
And so what you do is a descent
A descent into your own foolishness and stupidity
Level, by level, by level
And that's what Dante was trying to explain
That's what that hell was
Levels of catastrophe and there's something right at the bottom
And he found that it was betrayal that was at the bottom
So in any case I was reading that
And there's a line in there that made me remember this dream
Cause I tried to figure out this dream for years eh
So that was like a herald of the arrival of this messenger
It's a very powerful scene
And I thought about this dream with this thing with the four storms
So
The pipe thing that really, that really took me forever to figure out
And I finally remembered this painting by Magritte
This is not a pipe
Right so what does that mean?
Well what it means is the representation is not the thing
It's a very famous painting right?
The representation is not the thing
Well even the perception is not the thing
And that's what the dream was trying to get at
It's like this thing
This thing that was so powerful and so capable of transforming
Could be encapsulated temporarily within a conceptual system
But whenever it decided to leave it was just going to leave
And so
What is was referring to was the potential that there is inside objects
So for example
And it's such a complicated thing to explain
Nobody knew what cell phones were going to do
You make the cell phone
You think you know what it is
You don't know what it is
No one knew what the birth control pill was going to do
You make it, you think you know what it is, you have no idea what it is
And it's going to do some of the things you think it will do
And it's going to do a bunch of things you have no idea about
And that's because
Things are more complex than they look
They're multi-dimensional and they have
I wouldn't say a life exactly but they have an intrinsic complexity
That tends to unfold across time
And it's only somewhat predictable
And so you have things under your control and in your grasp to some limited degree
But at any point it's like the switch in the yin yang symbol
At any time chaos can collapse into order
Or order can collapse into chaos
And that's what that dream meant
Another painting by Magritte trying to express the same thing right?
All men in suits, all uniform, all thinking the same way
Same haircuts, completely socialized
Blinded by their own perceptions
That's us
Cause you think well your perceptions illuminate and bring you information
It's yes and no
They also constrain to equal degree
I dreamed much later about a year later
This was a very cool image too
You know that image I think is it  Da Vinci or Michelangelo
Of the man inscribed in the square inside the circle
It's a very famous image
Well it was like that except
It was a cube and not a square
And so there was kind of a faceless person, almost like a mannequin inside this cube
And he was suspended about two feet off the ground
And on the front wall
It was like wall paper designs, there were these little squares about this big
And they mandalas square with circles inside them
And then inside the circle there was a little snake tail that was out
And the whole wall was covered with these snake tails
And the person
When the person walked forward the wall would move forward
And when he walked backwards the wall would move backwards
So it was always this far away
And he could reach out and pull any of those snakes into being
And so that was another dream of the same sort of idea
What do you have in front of you?
A world of objects
No
You have a world of potential in front of you
And you can interact with any aspect of that potential
And while you're doing so, you realize it
You pull something into being that wouldn't have been there before
And what you see in front of you is a wall of potential
The potential is not infinite because you're constrained
But, it's still
For all intents and purposes it will do you just fine it's more potential than you could ever need
And so the dream
See dreams
Dreams are at the forefront of thinking
They get there before you
The creative imagination is at the forefront of thinking
If you think that you're moving out into the unknown
To gather new information
What gets there first is the imagination
Obviously that's what Piaget says about children as well
You imagine it first
Then maybe you can represent it in speech
And a dream is part of that imaginative process
That's what artists are doing
They're going out into the unknown
And representing it imaginatively
So what does that painting mean?
Well if the artist knew that he'd just write it down
Right? The art is beyond what's articulable otherwise it's not art it's just propaganda
So the artist and the dream their out on the frontier right? That's the open imagination
And so when you're conceptualizing new things
The dream and the imagination can bring you places that you don't even know that you can go
And it's a mystery too
It's like I don't know how I figured this out
It was as if the figuring out manifested itself inside me
Cause that's the experience in a dream right?
You don't feel "I dreamed this up"
You feel "I had a dream." Where did that come from?
It springs out of the unknown and offers something to you
Here's pathology as conceptualized by the phenomenologists
It's a very interesting way of thinking about it
Existential guilt and fear as debt to possibility
Well so there's this idea
It's like an exisitential idea that you have some problems
That you have some problems in your life
Well part of the Dasein is the sense of responsibility that you have to address those problems
It's part and parcel of the way that human beings manifest themselves in the world
So part of your pathology would be failure to bear the responsibility for your being
And a sense that you have a debt to your existence
And according to the phenomenologists that's built right into the sense of your being
It's a remarkable conceptualization
Right well that's a good place to stop
Okay good we'll see you in a week and a half